first off I'd like to say
congratulations on the special it is
incredible it's maybe my favorite thing
Marvel's ever done so you have quite the
entry to the MCU uh here this year thank
you thank you so much thank you I'm glad
you liked it you're welcome and I wanted
to know because this film is so or the
special is so heavily inspired by old
horror films of the 30s and the 40s and
the 50s was there anything you look to
specifically when you were researching
or were there any films any actors in
particular that you looked at oh yes
absolutely I mean apart from the from
the most direct ones you know which
would be the English-speaking
um films that that uh that were made in
those days uh there were also I saw some
crazy ones from from actually from you
know from the Bulgaria uh you know
Eastern Bloc area that were quite in
interesting as well and and also some
comedies as well in
um from Latin America in those days
and uh and and so you know the whole
world of of monsters and definitely of
werewolves is absolutely open you know
where you can you know the opportunity
to to engage into this project was a
chance to uh to really be free to
interpret and to color this character
the way we wanted uh and and it's very
difficult in in one hour to you know to
tell this kind of vast kind of uh
biography or let's say the the the
construction of this character uh
because uh you know it's a character
that has lived 400 years maybe there
were many things that were that would
set the tone and set the musical scale
of what we wanted to do
um there were many things that I would I
was also interested in pondering around
this
um and uh and and I'm still you know
incredibly curious and uh and wanting to
uh to you know to see where these
characters lives go you know where where
does this kind of develop
um and I love I love playing a monster
is fantastic it's it's great it's it's
very free and very uh
daring and uh and experimental as well I
was gonna say you've done horror a
couple of times you know with this and
you also did old last year is there
something about that genre in particular
that appeals to you or is it just
something that kind of falls into your
lap with specific projects yeah well I
actually thought that it was something
that I was completely away from you know
like I had never done something close to
this
um because I I mean I I don't know why
you know but but I'm really fortunate
that now I'm able to do this because it
is one of the I've always had a lot of
respect for for the horror genre you
know because it's uh it's got um it's
the most optimistic kind of uh stylized
version of of Cinema in a way
and uh and I love that it can go
anywhere you know it can lead anywhere
there's a there's a whole there's a lot
of moments in cinema in in horror
because what you see what you don't what
sorry what you don't when what you don't
see and what you don't listen to is as
important as what you see and what you
listen
so there's key rules you know that kind
of put are put together and and uh and
and the whole invitation is also how to
break them you know how to break this
person how to play with this and and so
I I love I love being uh part of this
because it is uh it is the way I like
also to do films not not for the sakes
of of me playing a character that will
give me this or that you know or will
satisfy this or that kind of curiosity
in me but but I mean most important is I
want to do films that are good
uh it doesn't matter the character in a
way uh you know and and so I I'm really
glad to eat and so lucky to be part of a
world like this I can imagine joining
something as big as Marvel at this point
in your career is is quite different
from other things that you've done
before at least in terms of scale I
would imagine it is very different yes
it is very different but at the same
time it is the the best possible way to
uh you know normally maybe from the
outside it would seem like uh it is uh
you know getting into a place that has
its its rules and it's kind of uh but
what what I heard even before getting
involved in into this was uh from all
the actors was like oh you will be in a
place where there's a lot of of room to
invent and to experiment you know I mean
there's there's many things that you can
play with and it's true it's true here
we would every day we would come up with
new ideas and and uh and we would
retract from certain ideas that were not
so good you know that we were that we
thought and now maybe that's not such a
good idea but we would really try it try
out things and uh and that's fantastic I
I mean what a great opportunity to to be
able to have a lot of time I mean we
shot this in five weeks uh for a for a
50-minute film you know also it's a a I
love it I love it it's really fantastic
I mean it's the best place to to be able
to experiment and to and to play around
and uh and monsters I mean I it's such a
I don't know it's such a
odd like a great vast place where we can
try out many many different things and
I'm really really happy and and not in a
way awesome well that was my last
question for you so thank you so much I
really appreciate it yeah thank you so
much take care
in your background thank you thank you
it is yeah